this is Fox News learned as we just told
you the New York Times released tonight
new information on a decade of the
president's taxes trace Gallagher has
been taking a close look at what they
put out there and joins us with an
update on it trace hi Tucker we're
scanning the article it's important to
note off the top the tax records do not
include information or tax years at the
center of the president's escalating
battle with Congress there are no
allegations of crimes or financial
misdeeds instead the records go back to
the late 80s Early 90s years the
president has already admitted were at
the very least tumultuous for example
The Times is reporting that by the time
Donald Trump's art of the deal book hit
shelves in 1987 he was already in deep
financial distress meaning tens of
millions in debt and during the decade
from 1985 to 1994 The Times says Trump's
losses totaled just over 1 point 1
billion dollars remember this is
investors and loan money primarily a few
points there during that time mr. Trump
bought Eastern Airlines shuttle for 365
million it never turned a profit and he
was spending upwards of 7 million
dollars a month to keep it up and flying
and his Taj Mahal Hotel and Casino it
opened in 1990 with more than 800
million in debt and to keep the Taj
floating Trump's businesses pulled money
from other casinos placing them in the
red as well now The Times is reporting
because of all the losses that that
Trump paid no federal taxes in eight of
the 10 years Charles J Carter who's a
lawyer for the president told The Times
on Saturday that the information was
demonstrably false and the statements
about the tax returns 30 years ago are
highly inaccurate saying and I'm quoting
here IRS transcripts particularly before
the days of electronic filing are
notoriously inaccurate and would not be
able to provide a reasonable picture of
any taxpayers returns we should also
point out the Times did not obtain the
actual tax returns they got the
information from someone who was
unidentified who had access to the tax
information we're still scanning Tucker
if we come both more stuff we'll bring
it to you
okay wait till they get yours in mine
Tracy Gallagher good to see you thanks